quiero saber a qué conjuntos de números
pertenece el 8 y bueno pensemos en todos
los conjuntos de números que hasta
ahorita hemos visto hemos visto para
empezar los números naturales así que
recordemos cuáles son los números
naturales déjenme ponerlo aquí números
los naturales
tú
y bueno habíamos dicho que los dos
naturales nos ayudan a contar por lo
tanto son los números que empiezan en 1
le sigue el 2 el 3 el 4 y así todos
estos ok si nosotros nos fijamos en los
números naturales supongamos que los
pongo aquí voy a poner aquí ambos
números naturales está estos son mis
números naturales ok entonces vamos a
ver si hay algún conjunto en donde estén
contenidos los números naturales el 8 si
es un número natural podemos contar 8
manzanas 8 peras ocho fotografías 8
vídeos de salman khan en en hd que se yo
todo lo que podamos contar y nos ayuda
como números naturales por lo tanto el 8
pertenece a los números naturales es más
déjenme ponerlo con el color que subraya
el 8 con este color vamos a indicar los
que sí son a conjuntos a los cuales
pertenece el 8 entonces los números
naturales en efecto son vamos a pensar
en el siguiente conjunto voy a pensar en
los números naturales voy a pensar en
los números
los naturales naturales naturales pero
ahora voy a incluir el 0 voy a incluir
el 0 por lo tanto voy a ponerle unión
el 0 0 ok ahora me estoy fijando en
todos estos y además en el 0 por lo
tanto los puedo poner otros por escribir
de la siguiente manera tengo al 0 al 1
al 2 al 3 al 4 y todos los que siguen
todos los que siguen por lo tanto son
todos los números con los cuales podemos
contar y le estamos agregando al 0 y si
te das cuenta si aquí tengo los números
naturales bueno pues este conjunto de
los números naturales unión el 0 también
tiene a todos los números naturales y
además tiene al 0 que está como por aquí
aquí voy a poner al 0 y entonces si yo
pego a estos 2 a estos 2 estoy
encontrando los números naturales unión
el 0 tengo a todos los números naturales
y aquí al número 0 y aquí ya tengo a
estos números naturales unión el cero
ahora el 8 si pertenece a este conjunto
de aquí a los números naturales unión el
0 porque está 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y el 8
está también aquí por lo tanto el 8 si
pertenece a este conjunto de lujo ya
tenemos 2 vamos a buscar el siguiente
conjunto qué
los números enteros los números
enteros
de 2 y bueno los números enteros
habíamos dicho que son todos los números
naturales por lo tanto lo voy a poner
aquí 1 2 3 4 y todos los demás pero a
estos le vamos a agregar el 0 le vamos a
agregar el 0 ok y la versión negativa de
todos los números naturales es decir
menos 1 y vamos para atrás menos 2 vamos
para atrás menos 3 vamos para atrás y
todos los demás por lo tanto estos son
los números enteros todas las versiones
negativas de los números naturales por
ejemplo en 1324 negativo está aquí así
llegamos hasta el menos 3 - 2 - 1 0 1 2
3 4 y nos seguimos 5 o 6 mil 324 mil 521
un millón 324 todos eso están y por lo
tanto si nos fijamos ahora en estos
conjuntos aquí tengo a todos los números
naturales hoy este círculo está muy
pequeño para los números naturales pero
imagínate que están todos ahí adentro
después le agrego al cero y ahora no
verifica en los números enteros y los
números enteros se ven más o menos así
tengo ahora a todos los números
naturales tengo al 0 pero también tengo
a la versión negativa de los números
enteros que por cierto se denotan con un
asceta con una c taborda ok
aquí están los números enteros de lujo
números enteros los naturales los
naturales unen el 0 y el 8 pertenecer a
los números enteros
claro que sí sí aquí tengo a los números
naturales bueno el otro está en los
números naturales y entonces está en los
números enteros de lugo si el 8 estaba
como por aquí por aquí tengo el 8 ok el
8 está incluido en los naturales en los
naturales unión el cero en los enteros y
qué números siguen bueno pues ahora
pensemos en los números números números
y racionales
si es bueno habíamos dicho que los
números racionales son todos todos los
números que se pueden ver de la forma p
/ q p / q donde p y q p y q son enteros
y bueno es que aquí hay un montón un
montón de nuevos racionales porque
estamos fijándonos en todos los números
que son razón de dos enteros
por ejemplo el un tercio el un tercio de
su número racional de que me ponen aquí
algunos a un tercio por ejemplo el cero
ciclar del cero sistema porque el cielo
lo podemos ver como cero entre dos y
sólo entre 12 0 por lo tanto si está lo
estamos viendo como una razón entre dos
números enteros o algún número entero
estará por ejemplo el 5 claro el 5 sí
está porque podemos decir 5 sobre 1 a 10
sobre 2 o lo que sea a el 8 y el 8 si
está porque lo podemos ver como 8 sobre
116 sobre 2 y 24 sobre 3 ok y bueno
también están sus versiones negativas
por lo tanto estoy diciendo que los
números racionales se verían más o menos
así incluyendo a todos los enteros y
además algunos otros números además de
los enteros porque también estamos
contando a todos los números que se
pueden ver de la forma
/ por lo tanto aquí voy a decir que
están los números racionales y por
cierto se oponen con una q con una q y
con un palito aquí aquí tengo los
números racionales y bueno si nosotros
pensamos en el 88 acabamos de ver que si
es un número nacional porque lo podemos
ver como el sobre 116 sobre 2 o lo que
sea por lo tanto si está en los números
racionales
ok pensamos ahora en los números
irracionales números números
irracionales y rancio
y bueno los números irracionales son
todos los números que no se pueden
escribir en la forma en que o dicho de
otra manera aquel número que no sea
racional va a ser irracional mientras
estemos en los números reales y bueno un
número irracional pues mucho me ocurre
por ejemplo raíz de 2 raíz de 2 si hay
varios más permitido que te des cuenta
es que el 8 como es un 9 racional por lo
tanto es una manera muy rápida podemos
decir que no es un número de racional no
hay ningún número racional e irracional
al mismo tiempo por lo tanto como el 8
racional no es irracional entonces estos
no éstos no ok y bueno si nosotros
queremos ver dónde están los negocios
nacionales
aquí tenemos por los conjuntos uno
dentro del otro es decir conjuntos
anidados bueno pues no motivacionales
tenemos por aquí nunca van a tocar
ningún racional ok pero están como por
aquí
voy a poner hasta acá a todos mis
números irracionales
que por cierto algunos los denotan con
la letra y una letra y gorda pero
también a los números imaginarios y
gritando no quiero meter en este
problema así que voy a poner aquí los
números irracionales irracionales o que
estos son los números irracionales ahora
pensemos en los últimos números que
hasta ahorita conocemos que son los
números reales números números reales
reales y bueno los números reales de una
manera muy sencilla los podemos concebir
como todos los irracionales unión los
racionales todos los irracionales unión
los racionales no quedarían es más
déjeme ponerlo con un color más fuerte
se me ocurre este de aquí me quedaría
algo así uno a estos con estos los pegó
ok si punto estos 2
a todos los unos reales y vamos a pegar
los lo más rápido que pueda
ok algunos o menos por así voy a pegar
los tal cual porque además no hay nada
de los números reales que no sea
racional o irracional por lo tanto estoy
poniendo a todos estos todos estos queda
súper pegados a estas líneas a estos
conjuntos porque estos son los números
reales
nuevos reales que se ponen con una r con
dos palitos a una hervor dan y aquí
tengo los números reales que son todos
estos los racionales unión los
irracionales y como el 8 racional
entonces también es real porque los
reales tienen los números racionales
están contenidos en los números reales
por lo tanto le voy a poner que si si es
un número real ahora ya acabé de
contestar la pregunta el 8 pertenece a
los números naturales que son estos a
los números naturales uniones 0 que son
estos a los números enteros que son
estos y date cuenta que estamos un
conjunto adentro de otro conjunto dentro
de otro conjunto a los nuevos racionales
que son estos ok a los números
irracionales no y ahorita te voy a
recordar porque ya los números reales
ahora quiero hablarte un poquitito de
los números irracionales si tú me
preguntas bueno cuáles son los números
irracionales tampoco existen números que
no se pueden poner de la forma entre q y
bueno el clásico ejemplo y lo que yo te
diría es que si fijémonos en pi pi es el
ejemplo por excelencia
es igual a 3.14 15 92 65 etcétera
etcétera etcétera etcétera y tan
etcétera que hay personas que dedican su
vida en aprenderse todos los dígitos
decimales de pib porque porque cumplen
dos cualidades fundamentales la primera
es que es un número que tiene punto
decimal infinito es decir que no va a
llegar a un punto en donde acabemos
vamos a seguir obteniendo y obteniendo y
obteniendo valores de pin y de hecho hay
páginas enteras teniendo números y
números y números de pin ok de los
decimales de pi déjame ponerte aquí es a
infinito decimal infinito decimal
infinito
y todo ok y además cumple otra propiedad
muy importante porque hay muchos números
racionales que tienen un decimal
infinito por ejemplo 0.3 333 333 333 que
es un tercio
pero además de que debe de ser decimal
infinito debe de cumplir que no tiene un
periodo no es periódicos decimal no es
periódico no
código periódico y creo que me falta un
acento periódico de lujo ahora por más
que nosotros le busquemos un periodo a
los decimales de pi nunca lo vamos a
encontrar y esa es una de las cualidades
importantísimas por las cuales estoy
hablando de un número irracional pero
bueno espero que todo esto te haya
ayudado mejor a entender cada uno de los
conjuntos de números